Judy Bautista how are you Judy rich how
are you I am doing very well better for
talking to you here on a very busy part
of our calendar year so unbelievable
what are so the competition committee is
meeting in New York is that what they're
meeting or they usually know down in
Florida they're in New York
you're here okay you're here in
Indianapolis and then they have a
meeting because they don't usually meet
in bad spots then they go to Naples
Florida in a few weeks
sure and then they go to the owners
meeting the big league meeting at the
end of the month so what are you what
are you hearing about their discussions
that could actually become placed before
the membership for a vote with a chance
to pass how about that threading that
needle well Judy well the catch rule you
know something's going to happen with
the catch rule because Roger Goodell
says he wants something to happen what
the catch rule so something's going to
happen from talking to them yesterday it
sounds like they're going to look at
eliminating the part about going to the
ground which is you know basically you
have to hold the ball not just going to
the ground but completing going to the
ground and it looks like that's going to
be eliminated and even though that
affects like a handful of ways a year is
the handful of players we all end up
talking about and debating I mean it is
the Dez Bryant non catch it's the Calvin
Johnson play
it's the Jesse James from the Steelers
this year against the Patriots touchdown
that was negated so it looks like if
there's a tweak it's gonna be bad well
do you know what the language would be
that no that's not done yet are this is
this is where they start the process
they look at a lot of film and they talk
for a lot of hours about what they're
going to do then they go to Naples at
that meeting and they really firm up
what they're going to do and then they
present it to the ownership for a vote
at the end of the month of March at the
big league meeting but essentially the
rule would stay the same except for
taking out the going to the ground where
you have to sort of complete going to
the ground with the ball intact so think
of what Dez Bryant did in that playoff
game and that would be a catch instead
of ananka
so it would be a bumble so what it would
be because he did not cross me plane no
that would be a catch because he had
control of the ball and he went down
with it but remember he they said the
ball moved he lost control of the ball
after he hit the ground
so it would be it would be it would be
settler - a fumble that if the ground
can't cause a fumble in a catch in the
same way a ground can't cause a fumble
when you're taken down to the ground as
a runner so your that's the what's up
that's the issue is what is the language
to make dez bryant runner as opposed to
somebody who's trying to complete the
process right right I mean that is
what's the language of how they're going
to do the language and that has always
you know from covering the competition
committee for years and I'm sure you
know this from talking to people at a
leak - it's really complicated to do the
language because whenever they think of
it the language it creates unintended
consequences that then they have to deal
with like next year tell me about it
that's that's the words I thought talk
rule come right I mean that's it right
there right so this is like the
competition committee dreads this every
year like I talked to a member of the
competition committee after Roger
Goodell said he wanted something done
with the catch rule and I said oh you're
looking forward to that and the person
responded ugh
oh that's they dread this they know that
by tweaking one thing they could be
opening a can of worms on the other
here's an example that somebody gave me
if you go to like you know you have to
just have two feet down and that makes
you that makes it a reception they said
that opens on the other side problems
with like changing the defenseless
receivable which is something that they
don't want to do because they don't want
weakened protections for a defenseless
receiver so those are the kinds of
things they have to consider all of the
unintended consequences when they go in
and change the language Judi Batista of
the NFL media group NFL Network joining
me in the Honda inside a report I did
see an al River Ron's tweets that the
conversation came up about fumbling into
the end zone and maybe looking at that
rule please tell me that that's on the
table that from that to the end zone
with the the funnel will go back the
spot of the fumble not handing it over
to a defense that's already on its high
yeah that they are discussing that and
that's another thing that I'll be
interested to see what they come out if
they come out with that change to vote
on but they they've discussed a lot of
things they discussed they've had a long
conversation about making defensive pass
interference just a 15 straight-up
15-yard penalty rather than a spot foul
that seems like a long shot right now
that that would pass this year but
they've had conversations about it
they've had conversations about a
targeting rule the way they have in
college that again seems like a long
shot but they've you know they spend a
lot of time going over a whole lot of
options and then they sort of winnow it
down when they go to the meeting in
early March and then they present what
they think has a decent chance of
success in front of the owners at the
big March meeting and and changing the
rules about not hiring somebody during
the playoffs did Josh McDaniels finally
push the needle towards changing that
well yeah I was told yesterday that that
ball has actually come before owners in
years past that has not generated arrest
support that they are sure that it's
going to get the support with that
incident fresh in everybody's minds
because ultimately let's be honest
owners don't like to be embarrassed and
that was an embarrassing situation for
the coach even though I think they
recovered really well they don't want
that to happen to another franchise any
idea what the Patriots vote on that rule
would be McDaniels door the day that
Bill Belichick goes off to Nantucket you
know for good you know you never know is
there any word about about that about
the meeting of the Patriot minds the
Brady Belichick craft Yalta what we were
talking about nope as as you well know
they make themselves scarce at a combine
we don't hear too much from from the
Patriots here so they go about their
business quietly they're here obviously
but they do not speak in the media and
they don't make themselves available so
no insight yet on that meeting whether
it's happened or what happened in it
okay Judy patty stay here on the Rich
Eisen show in the Honda in
a report so what is going on between
Roger Goodell and Jerry Jones or is one
member of the NFL media group asks
another what's going on between our boss
and one of our bosses what's going on
Judy well I think to phrase it better
it's one of our boss and all of the rest
of the bosses like I have been told by
more than one person like this is not a
Roger Goodell initiative the push for
this is from the other owners who were
not happy with Jerry Jones you know
threatening to sue members of the
compensation committee and you know
hiring David Boies and making that
public they were not happy with those
threats so the push to recoup the legal
fees that they incurred which are
apparently around two million dollars
may be in excess of that came from the
ownership so Jerry not surprisingly is
going to appeal that and that hearing is
going to be next week it'll either be
heard by Roger Goodell himself or
somebody he designates that smart money
is that Roger Goodell will probably
designate somebody to hear that on his
behalf
Wow any idea which week any idea which
owners are the ones knocking on the
commissioners door saying you got to do
something I was told if you polled
the owners there would probably be 28 or
29 who are in support of this Wow yeah I
was told it was owners were pretty angry
I mean you can go through the list of
people on the Compensation Committee
these are some of the most high-powered
owners in the league you know Arthur
Blank John there are Robert Kraft I mean
these are some of the most influential
owners in the league and they did not
appreciate being threatened by a fellow
longer I think
what bothered most of them I think as
much as anything is like airing the lead
dirty laundry in public is not something
they usually do and this was very public
and very acrimonious and it was owner
vs. owner and they don't like that you
know and so they want to clamp down on
this and they have the means to do it
like there's a rule on the books that's
been there since al Davis and we're
gonna use it they're gonna exercise it
and
one for you judy judy Bautista and the
Honda inside rapport is close to Gerry
Jones's home is there what is going on
with Dez Bryant the Cowboys is there
because there's a lot of chatter there's
a lot of passive-aggressive 'ti to the
media there seems what what is happening
between these two you know you know
Stephen Jones addressed it a little bit
yesterday mostly with the Dallas area
reporters and I believe our James later
was there too and passive aggressive is
exactly the way I would describe it like
they are nobody's throwing their arms
around each other here there's a whole
lot of maneuvering and positioning and
Stephen Jones would not commit to
anything they're gonna meet and we'll
see but I I was struck by the tone of
Stephen Jones yesterday but it was
really non-committal and you know not
particularly warm
I didn't think no he said at one point
talking about Dez's you know sideline
demeanor and how it can be a distraction
sometimes which is as you know a third
rail subject for Dez Bryant and and then
mentioned about the that in how
sometimes it's great he did say that
that's the passive part of the
aggressive part and then said but based
on the totality of his work the body of
work meaning you know he hasn't had a
thousand yard catch season since 2014
and I read that I'm like wow so boy what
does that all mean they want him to take
less money or could they just basically
tell him audios do you think well I
certainly came away thinking they want
him to take loss money now having said
that I mean if they're willing to do
that I mean because the back side of
that is well sort of been saying
unspoken if you're not going to take
less money well right that's what we're
willing to do you make the decision
either take less money or thank you so
I'll be interested to see how that works
its way up and I agree with you I was
completely struck by the way Stephen
Jones framed his comments yesterday
because I thought there were a lot of
you know very carefully couched slap
there okay
and then I lied last one for you based
on the scuttlebutt and what everybody's
whispering they're in Indianapolis Judy
Bautista the color that you think is
best associated with Kirk Cousins purple
green not I don't mean the color money
but green yeah
brown brown or orange which one do you
think what's the color think he's gonna
look really good in purple just like
prints really good and purple hmm the
artist formerly known as the Washington
Redskins quarterback Judy thanks very
much appreciate beautiful music there
you go I'll see out there an indie
thanks for the the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience